donc constituer un peu le personnage
adel il est issu d'un milieu modeste un
milieu populaire issue de l'immigration
tunisienne si je ne m'abuse
voilà tunisienne il a passé son enfance
son adolescence dans une banlieue
française à longjumeau
et puis un jour il passe là comme ça du
côté des spotlight sur une scène dix
fois beaucoup plus souvent même beaucoup
plus grande que celle là avec un groupe
qui s'appelle les to be free le premier
boys band français
après il y en a eu d'autres adèle
comment ça s'est passé c'est en soi le
premier rebond de votre vie
comment ça s'est passé ce passage de
gamins de banlieue à une star du mal à
ça fait bizarre d'être ici parce que ça
va faire quinze ans que je n'ai pas mis
les pieds sur une scène et ça fait 15
ans que je paye les projecteurs sur mon
jeu je voulais juste féliciter les bugs
pour leur talent et et l'hommage à
partir un jeu ok t'es une chanson qui a
changé ma vie
voilà donc du coût de votre enfance en
banlieue
comment comment laventure de boys band a
débuté alors nous on a grandi à à
longjumeau qu'à une banlieue parisienne
dans des cités on est issu d'un milieu
assez modeste on était trois copains
d'enfance et ce qui nous a liés c'est le
sport et c'est aussi l'envi et le rêve
de former un groupe et être connaître un
succès parce qu'on avait on avait faim
on avait la niaque
on voulait on voulait se prouver à nous
mêmes qu'on était capable de faire un
faire un groupe
et comme disait la chanson on se voyait
déjà en haut de la fiche donc donc ce
qui nous à ce qui nous a vraiment animé
ces voix-là ces lettres 3 trois amis
d'enfance ont été inséparables et on n'a
rien lâché quoi on s'est dit allez on y
va on a un rêve où on va on va tout
faire pour réaliser ce rêve
alors comment on fait parce que c'est
pas tout de rêver moi je suis un grand
rêveur
pourquoi donc donc après il ya des rêves
réalisable et rêvent plus ou moins
loufoques mais là on a 20 ans à 20 ans
on a aussi cette insouciance on
à cette folie et est en fait c'est passé
on avait un petit peu de talent ça n'est
pas non plus des grands chanteurs on
était des danseurs à la base on a
beaucoup travaillé on a beaucoup répété
on s'est entraîné à faire des
chorégraphies des acrobaties donc j'ai
eu du travail qui était important et je
pense que ce qui nous a démarqué
c'est l'audace l'audace qu'on a eus
d'aller à paris et on a provoqué la
chance en fait on était au philip et
france participe à une émission
moi j'étais là une émission de mister
france deux beaux gosses une émission de
vos gosses et moi j'étais là pour les
soutenir et on y est allés parce qu'on a
vignes aussi une idée derrière la tête
c'était de rencontrer aussi des des
directeurs artistiques de maisons dix
des producteurs et et on s'est fait
repéré comme ça c'est à dire qu'il y
avait un directeur artistique et dans
les coulisses on faisait le show on
voulait absolument être repérés et il ya
un directeur artistique et de nuit qui
nous a dit ça tombe bien je
on est en train de monter un offert un
casting pour faire un post bande
nous on lui a dit on et déjà on est déjà
un gros to be free c'était notre nom et
et c'est parti comme ça c'est qu'on
rêvait d'être voilà comme les new kids
on the block l'exacte et j'ai après
c'était un tourbillon de quoi savais que
ça démarre c'est le décollage indirects
rien n'arrête le boys band
les concerts s'enchaînent les scènes
s'enchaînent c'est vraiment beau
lisbonne magna en même temps
le temps que va durer laventure cinq ans
cinq millions d'albums vendus faut quand
même le rappeler aussi
le côté strass paillettes c'est ce que
nous on voit entend téléspectateurs mais
laventure to be free s'est pas non plus
que de la rigolade
il ya des moments qui sont pas toujours
évident non plus durant durant cette
période là on s'est vraiment éclaté un
phare au stade je peux pas vraiment j'ai
presque de conte de fées non mais c'est
vrai c'est ce ça fait vingt ans déjà
c'est aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
ce que je fais aujourd'hui parce que
c'est ce qui est important c'est le
moment présent et puis le passé j'ai un
peu du mal à en parler parce que c'est
loin derrière moi je regrette pas un
c'était génial mais il ya eu aussi
effectivement des moments de doute
moi j'ai cru que le bonheur c'était
c'était d'être célèbre finalement avec
le recul je pensais que c'était les
paillettes c'était c'était c'était voilà
déjà voilà tu as beau genouilly ccr on a
tous c'est vrai qu'on avait tous mais
c'est vrai qu'il manquait quelque chose
moi j'ai l'impression d'être dans une
espèce de prison dorée et puis j'étais
on sait que c'est comme une drogue ces
métiers donc je me suis dit comment je
vais me défaire de ça parce que je
manquais de liberté en fait quand on est
célèbre on aime nous c'était vraiment la
folie et ans et moi je n'avais pas
l'impression j'avais l'impression
d'étouffer totalement dans le regard des
autres et et j'avais envie
j'avais aussi envie de voir là d'autres
choses je me savais pas quoi surtout que
vous le disions c'était on s'est appelé
1 il ya quelques il ya quelques semaines
on me disait aussi à un moment donné l'
aventure to be fluent après cinq ans
elle s'arrête là vous étiez dans le
rebond en plein vol et puis être à coup
on retombe
le téléphone sonne plus vous on vous
connaît par votre prénom aden il faut se
faire un nom de famille aussi comment ça
se passe cette cette chute ces quelques
années quand même difficile dans votre
camp vous dire c'était trois ans très
difficiles dans ma vie vraiment très
difficile parce qu'on 11
je me disais c'est comme une drogue donc
on a envie que ça continue on a envie on
se dit on va voilà on se dit on se dit
c'est pas possible ça va pas finir c'est
la fin moi je vois elle s'était c'était
c'était un moment de bon en fait la
descente s'est fait progressivement
et puis j'ai eu une série parce que
souvent dans la vie on a des série de
mauvaises nouvelles
ça moi j'ai perdu mon père les to be
free s'était finie donc je ne savais
plus un sentiment de vide et c'est vrai
que
on a peur du vide on a tous peur de
l'inconnu finalement donc je savais plus
qui j'étais vraiment j'étais adel des to
be free mais c'était pas moi ça c'est
voilà je me suis dit c'est fini il faut
que donc beaucoup d'angoissé beaucoup
d'incertitudes et puis des problèmes
d'impôt waimes avec ma femme avec qui je
venais d'avoir un enfant qui m'a quittée
voilà une série de catastrophes dans ma
vie où c'était voilà vraiment été la
descente
là j'ai touché le fond c'est à dire ça
touché en trois ans où je devais toucher
le fond ça peut être et que je me suis
j'ai fait aussi une ouais j'ai touché le
fond j'étais j'ai fait des conneries
quoi je suis beaucoup sorti touché aux
drogues à l'alcool
et puis j'étais en pleine dépression et
c'est pas grave de l'ue jour là je suis
quelqu'un de pudique mais teddy que je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de bienveillance
et est donc je oui j'ai connu une
dépression qui m'a qui a permis aussi de
faire un travail sur moi me dire comment
je vais faire le deuil de ça parce que
finalement le plus dur c'était ça c'est
de se dire cesser d'accepter la fin
d'une d'une aventure avec des copains
d'enfance et ça c était très dur où ils
déclic il vient il vient quand il vient
comment pour justement 10-0 touché le
fond mais ça permet aussi de nous voyons
bien sûr le déclinisme la seule alors
ici on oui il ya eu un déclic quand même
eu un déclic
en fait j'ai été voir ma mère souvent
dans les moments où on va pas bien on va
avoir notre maman
et elle m'a dit quelque chose qui voit
là m'a posé une question
elle m'a dit adel est ce que tu en a
profité et cette question en fait je me
suis rendu compte d'une chose c'est
c'est eh je lui ai répondu oui maman à
fond vraiment en a profité à fond
c'était et en fait j'ai réalisé que
c'était
c'était une vie c'était juste une vie
mais finalement dans la vie on a
plusieurs vies et je me suis dit ok
c'est bon j'ai compris c'est une vie qui
est d un derrière moi et voilà après
après voilà il ya un nouveau chapitre
d'une vie qui doit s'écrire donc il ya
aussi des angoisses j'en parlais la
feuille blanche qu'est ce que je vais
devenir
est ce que je vais faire mais ça m'a
pris quoi voilà ça m'a fait prendre
vraiment confiant conscience que que
d'accepter voilà c'est comme les
histoires d'amour qui finissent faut
accepter à accepter voilà et grâce à
votre maman du coup vous enfilez un
nouveau costume
après la chemise très ouverte des to be
fully là on va vous avez reboutonner
béatrice donc vous démarrez autre chose
oui cette fois c'est on peut vraiment
prendre cette image c'est un nouvel
envol c'est dans l'aviation que vous
débutez ouais mais ça s'est fait petit à
petit on va dire parce qu'aussi il ya
une question qu'on pose moi j'ai des
enfants
on peut on poser cette question aux
enfants qu'est ce que tu veux faire
quand tu seras grand
c'est hyper quand même assez difficile
de répondre arrondi je veux faire
pompiers où médecins et moi quand je me
suis posé cette question
1 c'était j'arrivais j'avais pourtant
j'ai j'étais coach et j'étais je voyais
un thérapeute j'avais des amis autour de
moi c'est très difficile de trouver ma
voie en fait et ça s'est fait
progressivement
déjà le deuil du monde du showbiz et
puis ça m'a fait du bien aussi de
redescendre les pieds sur terre et est
depuis de ne plus dépendre du regard des
autres parce que ça c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui motive m'empêcher
d'être libre de prendre le métro de
faire mes courses donc donc une fois le
deuil passé je me suis qu est ce qui me
plaît qu'est ce qui me plaît dans la vie
qu'elles sont mais mes compétences
qu'est-ce que j'ai qu'est ce que je peux
tirer positif aussi de la nature to be
free
parce que c'est il ya des choses
évidemment très positif donc j'ai fait
une espèce de bilan de compétences et
j'en ai tiré bah voilà les to be free
j'ai appris l'anglais je parlais pas
anglais
vachement bien j'ai voyagé dans le monde
entier
vachement bien aussi j'ai aussi fait des
rencontres est extraordinaire donc là
aussi un carnet d adresses donc il y
avait ça d'un côté donc voilà ce que je
pouvais tirer les expériences et aussi
mes envies et est en fait avant
l'aviation d'affaires je vous raconter
comment j'en suis venu à ça à louer des
avions parce que je loue des avions
privés mais j'ai travaillé dans
l'événementiel parce que j'aimais bien
aussi organiser des fêtes et j'avais
comme client un constructeur d'avions et
j'ai fait un événement pour eux il était
tellement content qu'ils m'ont dit adel
si tu veux tu peux être notre
représentant commercial pour vendre de
la location d'avions d'affaires et en
fait ça correspondait aussi un rêve j'ai
toujours rêvé de voler de savoir voler
en fait et j'ai été fasciné par les
avions vraiment facile et depuis que je
suis tout petit je suis fasciné quand je
vois un avion je me dis même aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas toujours pas comment ça
décolle
et après c'est vrai que en fait dans les
rebonds comme ça le plus difficile c'est
d'avoir confiance en soi et et ça c'est
venu aussi avec un travail ou voilà je
vous parlais du parapente parce que ça
m'a beaucoup apporté au niveau la
confiance en soi ça c'était ans j'ai
commencé le parapente en 2010 c'est là
où j'ai créé ma société à genève
en fait c'est une société de
conciergerie privée dans le luxe
spécialisé dans la location de jets
privés et et voilà j'aime bien cette
photo parce que ça ça arrive hoc voilà
cette espèce de nouveaux départs d'envol
de prise de risque aussi parce que quand
on est entrepreneur et j'apprends
toujours un on apprend tout le temps de
façon dans la vie on apprend on fait des
erreurs aussi
mais mais parce que ne faut pas que j'en
fasse en parapente c'est assez dangereux
mais voilà ça m'a permis vraiment le
parapente d'avoir d'avoir confiance en
moi est de voir la vie avec un nouvel
horizon là vous le disiez vous êtes
employé pour ce grand groupe en même
temps toujours la niaque toujours
l'envié d'être indépendant d'être soi
même et c'est là vous décidez de faire
autre chose de prendre vie en main
totalement exactement il parapente c'est
ça c'est vraiment on a on allait les
suspentes en as les commandes et on se
dit voilà je prends ma vie en main et
parce que je me suis dit peut-être que
je peux avoir
je peux ouvrir une galerie d'art ce
qu'il ya plein de choses qui
m'intéressent dans le sud mais c'est
vrai que l'aviation d'affaires me
fasciner et et voyage c'est un bolide
d'envol le voyage aussi qui m'a toujours
il m'a toujours fait rêver aujourd'hui
comment vous analysez après 20 ans
justement ces trois périodes de votre
vie qu'est ce que vous en tirez comme
comme le sont si je puis dire
alors moi un film avec le recul je me
dis qui m'a permis de rebondir
déjà bon c'est vrai que je suis bien
entouré on va dire c'est très important
d'être bien entouré dans la famille les
amis
mais c'est aussi mon côté positif dans
la vie j'adore apprendre jésus toujours
quelqu'un très curieux et je vois
toujours le verre à moitié plein
d'avenir
les commandes pour elle elle cache eric
a maintenant un nom de famille aussi ma
ça marche bien mon activité aujourd'hui
donc donc je continue
je continue non ce qui est drôle c'est
que finalement j'ai beaucoup de clients
dans le show business en france
et finalement je reviens la musique avec
avec avec des artistes que j'admire et
mais je sais que c'est ça va je sais
qu'il y aura une autre vie après un
autre bon je sais pas lequel encore là
vous y attendez il ya autre chose qui va
arriver
moi j'étais pas pouvoir je sais pas quoi
encore mais cette façon la vie elle est
imprévisible et puis moi je fonctionne
beaucoup par par instinct par intuition
j'ai pas je n'aime pas les carrières
comme ça j'aime bien les aventures voilà
là du coup ça nous permettrait peut-être
vous réinviter une autre merci